all right you guys where's my East
Coasters at I love that I am painfully
from the East Coast to the point where I
have a Red Sox tattoo on my wrist you
guys yeah yes say thank you it's my
uncle um like it's so ridiculous like
it's Here I am garbage I'm aware like
it's on my wrist still technically a
[ __ ] stamp that's how that works it's
great I'm so happy to be here especially
tonight there are no Boston sports teams
playing tonight which means my parents
might actually be watching my set yeah
very exciting I'm originally from a town
called Linn right outside the city of
Boston nope you don't know where you
don't know no Lin is a real garbage fire
of a city if you're unfamiliar it's very
dangerous they've a slogan to warn you
about how bad it is the slogan for Lin
is Lin Lin city of sin you never come
out the way you came in yeah the
craziest part about that is that that's
been around since the 1600s you guys
yeah we've been a nightmare for hundreds
of years it's so dangerous my dad went
out one night to run an errand he went
to go to the ATM and a bunch of guys
tried to mug him but we had no money
growing up so in a turn of events my dad
ended up mugging them yeah
justice both my parents are crazy my mom
- she loves to try to give me advice but
she kind of always mixes up sayings so
the other day she goes you know what
Valerie life's not all guns and roses
now she wants grandkids that's the fun
he'll I get to live she called me up the
other day she goes hey Valerie I have an
idea how about we freeze your eggs we
get some of your boyfriend's sperm and
then I'll carry your baby no no uh-huh
so what kind of Italian mothers
Handmaid's Tale are you trying to weave
it's like that's not happening she goes
why I said science mom you are 60 years
old she goes my pouch is still good I
was like oh my god where is this even
coming from she goes I'm sorry they had
margaritas on draught tonight
[Applause]
technology's getting crazy now - right
everybody's getting those home
automation systems you know Google home
Amazon echo the thing I find fascinating
is they're all voiced by women if you
guys realize that they're never voiced
by a man and I think it's because the
tech companies knew if it was voiced by
a man no woman would buy it huh because
like none of us want to come home get
comfortable
unhook our bra and all of a sudden just
here
welcome home Carol like Jesus suddenly
you're just like gonna choose your own
home invasion you're like what it's
going on they have such cute names for
the women - right Syria LexA very classy
you know if it was voiced by a man it
would be like the bro iya stuff noxious
name right like the commercials would be
like who welcome to Samsung's Tyler
going on like if it was voiced by man -
you know it wouldn't do anything we
asked it - right why start now
we'd ask it something - simple - right
we'd be like hey Tyler can you turn on
the lights and it would just be like
literally all it would do now there's
there's an app for everything now you
guys remember face app when everybody
was doing that that was one where you
would upload a photo of yourself and it
would show you what you would look like
in 50 years I'm like
no thank you huh I'm a white woman in my
30s I don't want to know what I'm gonna
look like tomorrow like if I'm gonna
give my information away to like
probably the Russian government like
show me something useful you know like
show me what I would look like if I
stayed with my ex you know show me what
it would look like if I wasn't drowning
in student loan debt you know I want to
know what freedom looks like
my favorite though is that now you can
make a doctor's appointment with an app
but they only give you 50 characters to
explain what's wrong I think it's so
creative I was like okay uh House Season
six Episode four right figure it out you
know you guys have been so great thank
you so much
[Applause]